laurent fabius est l'invité de preuves
par 3 alors que son application se
confirme dans la préparation de
l'alternance éventuel en 2012 laurent
fabius bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes donc l'homme du du projet et
des premières décisions
pour 2012 on dit même que certains
décrets certains textes de loi sont sont
rédigées sont prêts sur ce point et
christine pouget de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire vous
interrogera dans un instant ce sera le
tour ensuite de perrine tarneaud de
public sénat sur un mode plus personnel
nous verrons que vous êtes aussi l'homme
d'autres passions que la politique et le
pouvoir d'abord vous êtes clairement
aujourd'hui déterminé en faveur de
dominique strauss kahn est ce que pour
vous ce sera le candidat alors que
françois hollande on le voit dans les
sondages semble réduire son écart dont
les choses pour moi se présente un peu
différemment d'abord site au mois de
juin nous l'avons décidé que nous ferons
notre choix bien d'autres partent pour
moi il ya beaucoup de personnalités qui
ont du talent au ps mais je pense que
les deux personnalités qui sont les
mieux placés pour gagner ensuite pour
présider sont martine aubry et devait
les fourcade et nous ferons le choix au
mois de juin il n'y a pas d'alternative
puisque l'un ou l'autre
bien sûr bon c'est sûr françois hollande
quand même fait une percée au préparer
oui mais françois hollande a beaucoup de
qualités mais si vous voulez moi mon
choix se fonde sur quoi il s'agit de
désigner quelqu'un qui puisse gagner et
puis après être prises dans l'appui
or je pense que l'expérience
gouvernementale dans la situation
actuelle la légitimité internationale en
matière économique et sociale et puis la
capacité de réunir son sont pas tout à
fait importante
or je crois que je crois mon la
conviction c'est que martine aubry et
dominique strauss kahn serait mieux
placé mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
personnes françois hollande ségolène
royal et d'autres qui si nous gagnons
devront faire partie de l'équipe de la
victoire est ce que vous redoutez ce
qu'on appelle maintenant communément
semble-t-il l'atterrissage de dominique
strauss kahn en france
s'ils devaient être connus de la non
pourquoi
un arbitre pourquoi voulez-vous parce
que on lit par exemple l'un de ses
proches qui déclare dans l'express cette
semaine qu'il n'a pas du tout conscience
de la machine à laver que représente la
bataille de l'elysée bon je crois qu'il
est doté d'une certaine conscience bon
et puis faites bien attention à cela
ceux qui parlent ne savent pas et ceux
qui savent ne parlent pas bon alors
qu'est ce qu'on va faire la france en 45
minutes vous quand vous avez changé à
part et d'autre est ce que vous vous
souvenez vous souvenez forcément des
primaires de 2007
j'irai perdu la main assez vite quand
même dsk non je me souviens de plus que
j'étais arrivé là où nous le rappeler et
c'était très intéressant parce qu'il ya
des conclusions en tirez nous étions
trois candidats ségolène royal dominique
strauss kahn et moi même et nous avions
été écrabouillé par ségolène royal
pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque on disait
eh bien
elle va gagner à coup sûr et les deux
autres strauss kahn faq sont très
compétents très bien etc
mais ils vont perdre donc ces arguments
très forts dont les choses se sont
déroulées autrement mais en tout cas ça
signifie quoi ça suffit cette fois ci
nous avons le temps de préparer à la
fois la primaire et puis le gouvernement
que nous allons utiliser ce temps et moi
je souhaite que la primaire soit bien
maîtrisé ce sera le cas je suis
optimiste
vous voulez une primaire de validation
comme on dit aujourd'hui non j'utilise
le maximum de division non alors ça
c'est vous mettez l'accent sur le
central tous les gens que je rencontre
socialiste ou voulant simplement un
changement sans être socialiste
il disait douter ont pas daigné kaka
mais surtout surtout surtout ne vous /
et moi mon rôle
compte tenu de ce que je représente dans
le parti socialiste et puis de mon
expérience c'est d'être un de ceux qui
veillent à l'unité et ça je le fais et
je le ferai
alors nicolas sarkozy a défendu il ya
quelques jours son bilan que vous
attaquez c'est bien normal mais ce que
vous reconnaissez que le rsa est un
maître dans la colonne réussite
alors en ce moment quand on parle du rsa
c'est pas exactement sous l'angle du
bilan de réflexion jeux bilan et sur le
rsa si vous voulez sur le bilan je
voyais une réaction de collègues mais
mes nouveaux collègues l'autre jour on
lisait ce que le bilan est positif ou
pas et il avait une réaction très
pertinente izem ai fait moi la liste de
ceux qui marchent mieux dans le pays et
c'est ça ma question alors évidemment il
ya la crise bon mais je crois que si on
fait la liste de ce qui va mieux pour
les français ben on a fini et avant de
commencer donc le bilan n'est pas bon et
comme les gens le savent ça explique la
perte de crédibilité de monsieur sarkozy
sur le rsa ribbons le rsa avant il y
avait le rmi le rmi avait des défauts
donc on est passé au rsa le rsa bien
évidemment doit être complétée moi je
vois ça en tant que responsable local
mais c'est pour ça qu'on parle du récent
ce moment la proposition faite par
monsieur hockey
une proposition extrêmement choquante et
les syndics raison de s'alarmer
la gauche aussi monsieur fillon aussi il
ya eu raison de recadrer monsieur
wauquiez et au conseil des ministres
nicolas sarkozy vous êtes satisfait que
le chef de l'état s'implique pour donc
défendre a dit il une réforme
exceptionnelle celle du rl oui mais
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que
j'ai cru comprendre que monsieur
wauquiez avait lancé le thème de
l'assistanat
parce que l'entourage de monsieur
sarkozy le lui avait demandé
alors évidemment la réaction a été
extrêmement négative et donc monsieur
sarkozy désormais réagi mais j'aurais
préféré faire simplement oui le cancer
contrairement à ce qu'a dit monsieur
vous qu'est ce sont pas les personnes
qui sont au rsa
le cancer c'est le chômage et il faut
s'attaquer au chômage et pas s'attaquer
aux chômeurs mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas
des thèmes qui touchent les couches
populaires de notre pays laurent fabius
on peut parler de l'assistanat on que le
cheveu l'immigration on peut parler de
la nocivité est ce que le ps n'est pas
mal à l'aise avec toutes ces questions
pas du tout pro non tenues tels des
questions que vous voulez aborder
prenons l'exemple la sécurité donc moi
je suis locale depuis de très nombreuses
années je vois la réaction de tous mes
collègues maires socialistes n'a pas un
d'entre eux qu'ils soient contre la
sécurité on est tous pour la sécurité
mais pour des mesures efficaces qu'est
ce qu'on constate c'est que
la sécurité s'est plutôt détériorée
depuis des années parce qu'on a retiré
toute une série de policier de gendarme
du terrain parce qu'on ne fait pas assez
de prévention parce qu'on s'intéresse
pas si aux victimes
et donc nous avons je savais dans notre
projet pris des décisions extrêmement
concret est l'une des premières mesures
que nous prenons que nous prendrons
citiez ses premières mesures
c'est de redonner des effectifs ont mal
à leur police et de gendarmerie
parce que on ne peut pas assurer la
sécurité s'ils n'y a pas des gens sur le
terrain
alors je parle des couches populaires
parce que l'une des idées qui sont
prêtés à la fondation terra nova où on
compte 1 beaucoup de partisans de
dominique strauss kahn c'est en quelque
sorte de les abandonner de ne pas
vouloir les reconquérir et de mettre le
focus sur les classes moyennes que davos
est la première où c'était le 30e
anniversaire du nu mais on avait besoin
du peuple de gori on a parlé de françois
mitterrand françois mitterrand avait une
très jolie formule qui s'applique est ce
que vous venez de me dire il faut pas
prendre toutes les mouches qui volent
pour des idées d'accord fabien dont vous
manifestez de la distance il ne s'agit
pas d'abandonner les couches populaires
à la droite voire au front national
comme le plaide aujourd'hui en disant il
faut faire un choix
oui d'accord mais écoutez surpris quand
même si vous abandonnez les électeurs
vous pouvez faire des choses très
intéressantes mais pas de la politique
et pas
je souhaitais résider le pays il faut
que nous ayons un projet c'est ce que
nous avons prévu qu'est la fois tiennent
compte du fait que la situation
financière que nous trouverons ça pourri
parce que les questions étaient vides et
deuxièmement il faut faire un projet
sérieux et troisièmement évidemment un
projet juste parce que les efforts sont
nécessaires et un projet innovant c'est
au tour de sa queue on patine autres
élèves et qui concerne la fois les
couches populaires les couches moyennes
alors oui les entrepreneurs tous ceux
qui qui qui font preuve dans tous leurs
domaines dans tous les domaines
d'initiative
voilà rien il ya un personnage quand on
a peu parlé lors de l'anniversaire du 10
mai il est arrivé un peu plus tard c'est
bernard tapie est ce qu il est
encombrant sous tous les régimes à on en
parle aujourd'hui ou hier d'après ce que
j'ai vu dans la presse parce que on
reproche enfin reproche aux s'interroge
sur le rôle de la ministre économie des
finances et j'ai même cru comprendre que
le procureur général près la cour de
cassation demandé une enquête sur ce
sujet moi je veux dire tout simplement
la chose suivante puisque c'est plutôt
madame le garde chasse en cause encore
c'est que je ne pense pas quelques étés
son action qu'elle est à j
de son propre chef qui te regarder plus
haut c'est ce qu'a dit ségolène royal
oui elle a tout à fait raison il faut
regarder même tout le temps mais cela
dit puisque maintenant il va y avoir une
formulation exacte
une première carrière avant une
éventuelle instruction à la va savoir à
quoi sont cours de justice de la
république
un sujet dans l'actualité laurent fabius
l'a la venue en france de l'épouser
michelle martin l épouse de l'ancien
pédophile condamné en belgique marc
dutroux le garde des sceaux n'a pas
l'intention de dire oui à la belgique
pour sa venue à elle en france
manifestement un couvent est prêt à
l'accepter la même décision
j'aurais pris dans l'indécision les
crimes qui ont été commis sont horribles
la justice pour belge pour des raisons
qui lui appartiennent en décidé
d'abréger sa pelle mais c'est pas une
raison pour qu'elle vienne en france on
a parlé on va pas revenir sur le 10 mai
y on en a tellement parlé ces derniers
jours
ces derniers jours laurent fabius vous
apparaissiez vous comme l'héritier
naturel de françois mitterrand
aujourd'hui on en voit d'autres là on a
oui c'est vraiment dit que l'héritage
qui se glisse dans cepsa de ségolène
royal à françois hollande ça vous ça
vous fait découvrir
wissam ça me fait plaisir même pensé à
mettre au regard d'abord oui mais là
n'est pas contradictoire avec l'autre
moi j'étais évidemment son principal
collaborateur son ami mais c'est très
bien que aujourd'hui tout le monde se
réclame de fond sommités ans et il
aurait souri de 50 au lieu des baisses
que x y et mitterrandiste 10 euros
je pense que ça veut dire mais ça me
fait plaisir alors donc héritier naturel
pendant des années de françois
mitterrand du temps de son vivant
ailleurs et après et après après aussi
et le temps est avancé et puis ces
derniers mois où est présenté comme un
sage actif aujourd'hui comment est ce
que vous vous définissez puisque vous
avez vraiment les mains dans le projet
mais non ce terme est assez il demeure
version alors ya deux aspects il ya le
côté sale c'est ce que je vous ai dit
sur l'unité
je suis un des gardiens de l'unité parce
que avec la division en arrive à ril
d'accord
et actif puisque les socialistes m'ont
demandé de faire pas mal de choses pour
préparer notre radar c'est donc j'essaye
d'aider c'est ce qu'on va voir on va
aller plus loin dans un instant vécu
christine coget de la fp juste après
cette enquête sur vous laurent fabius
à un an de la présidentielle enquête
signée on regarde ça ensemble
mounir soucie pas encore de candidat au
parti socialiste mais un projet que la
direction tente de mettre en avant dans
cette mission laurent fabius est en
première ligne martine aubry a confié à
l'ancien premier ministre la lourde
tâche de préparer le changement
en cas de victoire de la gauche entouré
d'une cinquantaine d'experts laurent
fabius doit traduire les propositions
socialistes en un programme de
gouvernement mobilise des compétences de
l' expertise pour pouvoir dessiner ce
que sera la première année d'un
gouvernement de gauche
mais vu qu'il pilote ce projet ce serait
pas logique qu'il le fasse appliquer
matignon par exemple abdellah vous êtes
vraiment dans le coup d'après je crois
qu'il faut surtout s'engager maintenant
dans la préparation de l'élection
présidentielle c'est notre mission
collective façonner les futures réformes
socialistes
un bon moyen de se positionner pour un
poste important si la gauche s'impose en
2012 hier le ps fêter le trentième
anniversaire de l'élection de françois
mitterrand et rue de solférino personne
ne doute que laurent fabius aura un rôle
de premier plan si les socialistes
reviennent au pouvoir
même les anciens lieutenants de ségolène
royal vont de ses qualités
si quelqu'un pense qu'on peut se passer
de leurs sommes fabuleuses gouvernement
hypothétique après les élections
présidentielles je crois qu se trouve
laurent fabius a mis ses ambitions
présidentielles entre parenthèses pour
ses proches c'est d'abord une bonne
nouvelle pour le parti
le fait qu il place son destin personnel
au service du collectif lui permettrait
même de prendre de la hauteur
c'est vrai que ça lui donne du coup une
autorité peut-être plus forte parce que
m
impliqué personnellement un an de la
présidentielle laurent fabius semble se
mettre en retrait mais à bientôt 65 ans
celui qui fut le plus jeune premier
ministre de la vème république n'oublie
pas qu'il a le même âge que françois
mitterrand lorsqu'il est entré à
l'elysée il détient aujourd'hui un
statut qui le rend incontournable
voilà vous défendez l'unité du parti de
l'unité aussi pour vous même la marche
tant mieux si je comprends bien moi je
suis candidat plus on adore mais c'est
très très bien alors b pour être sérieux
martine aubry m'a d'abord demandé de
présider la convention sur la défense et
sur les aspects internationaux ce que
j'ai fait qui a été adoptée à
l'unanimité c'est très bien et puis
maintenant la préparation donc de la
première les gouvernements je précise
que après la première année il avec bien
sûr tout le monde
tout le monde sait que c'est la première
jamais complété les dessins dont vous
avez réuni déjà des experts jeu mais on
ne sait rien en fait de tout cela pour
nos murs et rester dans les dix ans
et pourquoi c'est resté dans la
discrétion le bluff parce que il faut
avant de prendre des décisions et les
décisions seront prises par le candidat
ou la candidate
il faut travailler préparer et on n'est
pas obligé au stade de la préparation de
mettre tout sur la place publique
mais concrètement a pas de mystère j'ai
demandé un certain nombre de
responsables du parti socialiste de
remettre si je peux dire des devoir et
le devoir je peux bien vous préciser
c'est premièrement qu'est ce que vous
proposez de faire partie du projet que
nous adoptons entre l'élection
présidentielle et les législatives
puisqu'il ya une période d'un mois où il
ya pas de parlement il faut quand même
agir deuxièmement que fait-on à votre
avis entre la victoire aux législatives
et l'année suivante et troisièmement que
fait-on dans les quatre années qui
suivent et je ramasse les copies
on discute avec les uns avec les autres
on fait les arbitrages les prêts
arbitrage on propose d'agir sous tel ou
tel domaine compte tenu des contraintes
financières
faut-il un référendum ou non qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'au premier mesures en
matière étrangères en matière de
politique intérieure matière de sécurité
en matière d'éducation et ce matériau
est bien évident
ex
vraiment utile au candidat ou à la
candidate et je remettrai donc ce
matériau mois d'octobre-novembre octobre
ou novembre
mais à qui vous le remettrait alors
est-ce que c'est vers l'arctique a
brillé en tout état de cause parce que
elle est première secrétaire du parti
sis et où ou candidat ou à la candidate
voilà et vos priorités si vous aviez à
nous donner une de vos priorités très
forte des exemples les minorités elles
sont définies dans le projet socialiste
qui a été bâtie sous la conduite martine
aubry qui a rassemblé l'unanimité des
socialistes et pas très fréquent donc
bravo je jouais donne deux exemples en
matière extérieure bon président la
république arrive il ne m'a gouvernement
immédiatement il ya une deux échanges
extérieurs
il y à la préparation d'un sommet qui
aura lieu à copenhague se met européen
où on parlera en particulier des du
cadrage financier pour les cinq années
qui suivent
c'est très important ça définit la
politique agricole la politique
industrielle extra faut près pas fait
cela deuxième exemple entre le 2 et le 4
juin
je suis prêt si en 2012 vous avez une
conférence à rio qui l'ensemble des pays
du monde et qui est le 20e anniversaire
de la conférence sur l'environnement de
rio et là il faudra que la france peut
être avec l'allemagne peut-être avec
d'autres prennent position sur des
grands sujets d'environnement et le
président de la république ou la planète
viendra d'être élu donc nous préparons
ces deux instants sur le plan interne
je vous donne un autre exemple le il y
aura un budget qui a été préparée par
l'ancienne équipe et il y aura des
propositions de suppressions de postes
dans l'éducation nationale
décidons nous ou non entre mai et juin
de suspendre ces suppressions de postes
la proposition et oui c'est concret
d'accord et vous pensez qu'une plus
grande justice sociale sera possible
avec l'état des comptes vous avez dit
pourrit tout à l'heure oui pourri et le
mot est fort mais c'est vrai que je suis
très frappé ans
en plus savez que c'est un domaine que
je connais bien pour a été ministre des
finances nous nous la france partira
avec un handicap considérable
c'est une situation beaucoup plus
détériorés que celle qu'ont connue les
gouvernements précédents qui aura pas de
mesures généreuses
il faudra donner à la gauche mais le
rythme y aura nécessairement des mesures
d'amélioration sociale mais à
l'intérieur d'un cadre financier qui est
ce qu'il est et donc il sera d'autant
plus nécessaire d'avoir un effort de
justice
quand on voit ce que le gouvernement
décide aujourd'hui même c'est à dire une
réforme de l'iace f qui consiste si on
enlève tout les éléments latéraux à ce
que les personnes les plus riches de
france paye moi qu'avant on sait qu'on
supprime le bouclier fiscal oui c'est
tout à fait vrai il aurait été plus
simple de ne pas créer de gros sur bon
c'est ce que nous avions dit monsieur
sarkozy nous a expliqué avec sa
conviction extraordinaire pendant quatre
ans que il fallait absolument le
bouclier fiscal parce que les allemands
n'avaient eux et puis maintenant on est
dit il faut absolument supprimer le
bouclier fiscal parce que les allemands
ne l'ont pas auprès de qui pourra bon
nous avons dit c'est injuste c'est vrai
mais on supprime le bouclier à bien avec
quand même 10 des leds retard ne sera
pas l'année prochaine donc entre temps
quelques dizaines de millions pour les
uns pour les autres et pour l' isf donc
alors que le taux us elle n'est pas du
tout un impôt
intangible il ya des choses à améliorer
mais là le changement qui est fait c'est
que là où il y avait un taux c'est
important pour les gens vraiment très
très riche on diminue ce taux par quatre
donc voilà c'est mon frère alors vous
avez là un programme varié va avoir une
réforme fiscale d'ensemble et se jetant
sur les la pauvre je pense on veut
rentrer les toboggans pense qu'il faut
reprendre l'ensemble c'est à dire je le
dis tout à l'heure quand on était une
situation qui demandaient des efforts
légitimes
attention aux faux plat sommet les gens
mais il est légitime qu'on contribue à
proportion à la fois de ses revenus et
son patrimoine
donc on reprendra la question de l'impôt
sur revenu des niches de niche fiscale
de l'impôt sur le patrimoine et nous
sommes en train de préparer cela c'est
pas ce qu'il ya de plus facile
est-ce que vous avez déjà des lois des
décrets qui sont préparés ou non et on
évoquerait j'ajoute que tout ça sera mis
à la disposition bien sûr de la
personnalité candidate et de certains
aspects devoir discuter avec tout
partenaire puisque il y a évidemment un
travail de partenariat nous entendons
gouverner avec l'ensemble de la gauche
et des écologistes
mais là ça permettra si vous voulez
d'avoir fait le travail en amont et je
pense que les français seront sensibles
à l'aspect très sérieux de l'équipe qui
va se présenter et vous avez déjà
commencé à avoir des contacts avec vous
justement ses partenaires sur ces alors
il y a un travail qui est fait par le
parti socialiste qui englobe la rose le
travail sur le fond on les travaille sur
les circonscriptions et le travail que
les partenaires en ce qui me concerne où
le candidat viendra dans le deuxième
prix vous avez des échanges sur ses
projets sur ces décrets ses premières
lois avec par exemple je donne le nom
dominique strauss kahn oui mais oui
j'ose pré-candidats aussi bien sûr mais
avec des ce cas vous échanger sur ses
premières rondeurs et écouter le n'est
pas mystérieux que
martine aubry et dominique strauss kahn
moi-même de même que ségolène royal nous
avons des contacts fréquents et
d'ailleurs c'est une des choses qui a
réussi extrêmement bien martine aubry
alors qu'auparavant les leaders du parti
n'avait quasiment pas de contacts
malheureusement elle fait travailler les
un réseau dense en vallée d'ossau
scanner une situation particulière
puisqu'il est au fmi et au fmi il n'a
pas à prendre des positions politiques
et il y est très attentif
c'est seulement au mois de juin à la
date qui prévu que dominés qu'en liaison
avec les uns et les autres nous dira ce
qu'il veut faire
est-ce qu'il n'a pas comme le dit
l'elysée aujourd'hui pris des positions
politiques depuis qu'il est patron du
fmi
est-ce qu'il n'a pas donné quitus
finalement la politique qui a été mise
en oeuvre depuis 2007 sur la réduction
du nombre de fonctionnaires sur normes
le report de l'âge de la retraite
d'abord il ya une règle c'est que
lorsque quelqu'un est directeur général
du fmi
il ne prend jamais position mais ces
jeunes charles et ses décisions sur le
rapport qui concerne son pays je suis
très normal
deuxièmement commentaires vos
commentaires parce que ce serait très
intéressant que vous commentiez un
article qui vient de sortir de joseph
stiglitz prix nobel d'économie et hommes
progressiste incontestable qui explique
que le fbi a commencé de changer avec
son nouveau directeur général
voilà c'est un argument quand on entend
beaucoup en france également pas se
toucher ses primes très bien parmi les
supporters de dsk
alors encore un mot sur bsk sur dsk oui
évidemment il ya eu l'image donc vous
pouvez parler aussi des autres oui oui
du match qui a fait le buzz évidemment
avec l'image de la porsche
et puis là maintenant on voit ce dossier
de l'express qui sort sur son patrimoine
immobilier
les oeuvres d'art de sa femme c est ce
que vous pensez que ça va être qu'un
camp gênant pour un candidat potentiel
de la gauche d'avoir un tel patrimoine
écoutez
beau sur la voiture d'après ce que j'ai
compris il était photographié à côté de
la voiture d'un ami je reconnais que
c'est un crime c'est important bon là
j'ai tâche énorme quand même retenu une
boulette
moi oui enfin il faut savoir quand on
fait campagne qu'il y aura des
paparazzis partout d'ailleurs le voir
quand une petite anecdote y avoir après
je reviendrai j'avais reçu chez moi un
grand quevilly au moment où diana était
morte la peau d'âme et je rappelle été
menée en bureau deros et c'est triste
quand même la mort de cette lady diana
j'ai dit oui et quand même ils sont
dégoûtants c'est pas parasites
ça m'était resté dans l'oreille bon
alors sur l'autre à faire c'était quoi
sert un jeu gênant la candidature celle
de la gauche dispose d'un tel patrimoine
scan a le train de vie d'un
fonctionnaire international voilà la
création d'un fonctionnaire
international et d'après ce que je
comprends son épouse est l'héritière
dynastie du robert qui était un marchand
d'art extrêmement connus fin du début du
xxème siècle voilà celui suppression de
fait mais ce qui compte je crois c'est
les positions que l'on prend et
comme tous les prêts candidat s'il était
candidat
de toutes les manières la démarche sera
inspiré du projet socialiste le projet
socialiste
c est un projet qui sur le plan fiscal
vous abordiez la question fiscale veut
établir plus de justice et qu'il fera
sur le clan du pouvoir d'achat va donner
du pouvoir d'achat à ceux qui en ont le
moins et qu'il n'acceptera pas la
logique actuelle des bonus nous ramène
toujours au progès est important enfin
de votre gestion des propositions wenger
on a donc célébré les 30 ans en 1981
françois mitterrand et il a été élu sur
sa personnalité c'était la victoire d'un
homme plus vieux vainqueur d'un projet
quand je demande dans quel domaine 2012
ne va pas déroger à la règle
ce sera la victoire d'un homme oui oui
il ya de ces questions importantes
effectivement qui bien sûr bain mais
puisque vous me parlez de 2011 call avec
tous ses défauts considérable que si on
avait le temps vous accumulez riez je
pense que c'est le candidat le plus
populaire de france
c'est vrai est ce que vous estimez que
certaines critiques sont nauséabondes
quand on l'associent à l'élite
mondialisée l'élite financière
est ce que vous y voyez certains roland
lui l'élite sais pas il ya des mots plus
bon et bien y avoir certaines d'arrière
pensées enrique reina
non si vous me demandez ce que la
campagne
sera la plus raffinée laquelle on est
assistée j'ai l'impression d'après les
premières escarmouches que la réponse
n'est pas nécessairement oui comment se
prépare à ce genre de situation on dit
en soi même tranquille et en faisant
confiance à l'intelligence des gens que
celle que pourrait faire dsk en fait
pour renforcer ce lien de proximité avec
les français
comment vous mais alors vraiment vous
voulez groupe a compté mission sur lui
mais il faut prendre les choses telles
qu'elles sont bons il a été député maire
d'une ville qui n'est pas totalement
denis sur scène sarcelles je sais pas si
vous êtes déjà allé à sarcelles bon ben
voilà il a été maire et si je comprends
bien mr très apprécié ensuite bon il a
été directeur du fonds monétaire
international il se trouve que le fonds
monétaire international trouve à
washington
à sarcelles bon tant qu'il est à
washington et à washington s'il décidait
de revenir en france je vous confirme
que il habite en france laisse imposer
ce sera votre dernière question
maintenant alors écoutez y avait une
question aussi n'est pas cela qui va de
mauvaises interprétations
je vous ai dit qu'il y avait en tout cas
dans mes préférences et puis beaucoup
d'autres mais deux personnalités qui
avaient les épaules question c'est sur
la grèce la situation de la grèce est ce
que ça vous effraie pas là on a
l'impression que je subjectivement l'art
visuel est sûre ça me rapproche un peu
du parce qu'il ya une réunion qui est
prévu donc du fmi et de lieu à la mi
juin est justement dsk devraient y
assister et je veux dire s'il n'y
assiste pas ça on verra bien mais en
tout cas sur le fond sur le fond je peux
vous dire que tout ce qui serait
hypothèse de sortie de l'euro est une
subtilité avant la vie que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour la grèce que ce soit
pour l'allemagne puisqu'on est
parfois on évoque les deux hypothèses
chose explique pourquoi les seconds bon
si la grèce décidée pour tout une
évasion de sortir de l'euro la grèce et
des dettes les dettes sont contre
interne euros si la monnaie de la grèce
n'est plus le rom et la drac
ça veut dire que du jour au lendemain la
grèce est obligé de rembourser 30 % de
plus donc c'est pouvoir d'achat 30% -
symétriquement si l'europe fonctionne
mal et que quand les allemands
il peut-être veulent que l'euro soit
réservé aux pays les plus forts l'euro
va devenir une espèce de deutsch mark
l'euro va prendre 30% de sa valeur et il
n'ya plus d'exportation allemande
donc nous sommes entrés de l'euro dans
l'euro l'euro nous donne une force même
s'il faut à mon avis mieux le gérer que
ces cas aujourd'hui par rapport au
dollar pas problème en chinois mais le
fait que nous ayons les pays qui
voudraient sortir de l'euro ce serait
pour eux et pour les autres
une contre-performance évidente fabien
merci christine coget vous redoutez une
campagne avec des boules puantes il y
aura peut-être des heureux évènement
durant cette campagne et laurent fabius
de notre côté en tout cas moi je conchie
forêt à une campagne digne parce qu'il
faut faire confiance à l'intelligence et
au jugement des français de l'autre côté
il y aura peut-être un événement heureux
c'est ce que l'on lit à la une des
gazettes people
je pense à carla bruni qui pourrait
devenir mère à nouveau à est ce que ça
pourrait peser politiquement en faveur
de son époux selon vous honnêtement
c'est un sujet tellement grave pour la
vie politique française et même mondiale
que j'hésite à me prononcer il faut
quand même avoir le sentais responsable
mais on en parlera beaucoup aller vers
un internaute de public sénat va nous
rejoindre laurent fabius
juste après ce reportage de tam tran huy
sur vos autres passions je les évoqué
tout à l'heure qui nous aider à ouvrir
qui vous écarte pas totalement un de
celles qui vous habite la politique et
le pouvoir
tam tran huy
un millier de personnes reconstituant la
cathédrale de rouen par monnet pour
rentrer au guinness des records
laurent fabius ne pouvais pas manquer ça
après trente ans de vie politique le
député socialiste dévoile un nouvel
aspect de sa personnalité
l'amateur d'art le chorégraphe angelin
prejlocaj a connu laurent fabius lors de
réunions du club de réflexion politique
fraternité pour lui la sensibilité de
l'ancien premier ministre n'est pas
feinte
et c'est seulement finalement sur la
maturité que les hommes acceptent avec
avec souvent intérêt finalement de
montrer ce qu'ils sont réellement on
sent bien que c'est quelqu'un qui a une
sensibilité à fleur de peau mais qui à
mon avis là
cette sensibilité il la cache la rente
c'est peut-être une protection d'hommes
politiques dans le cabinet des douze
politique et art sont intimement liés
l'objet du livre montré que l'âme de la
france s'exprime aussi par ses tableaux
ainsi l'impressionnisme incarne le
passage de la france rurale à la france
industrielle voltaire par quentin de la
tour illustre le siècle des lumières et
de l'impertinence l'artiste observe des
codes le monde quand le politique est
dans l'action mais les points communs
sont plus nombreux qu'on imagine c'est
vraiment un
un métier et une passion d'engagement
enfin c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
faire à moitié il ya il ya et de la même
manière que pour l'engagement artistique
et quelque chose d'absolu mais même dans
un ouvrage consacré à la peinture le
politique prend le pas jamais laurent
fabius mais aussi affûté que dans ses
chapitres consacrés à la vie
parlementaire et aux chefs d'état et de
regretter l'époque où les gouvernants
disposait d'une culture profonde de
répéter que l'identité française en art
n'existe pas le politique n'est donc
jamais loin comme quoi on ne
révolutionne pas trois décennies de vie
en 200 pages voilà perrine tarneaud nous
a rejoint perrine est ce que l'art peut
être un antidote à la politique non en
tout cas un percement c'est pas ainsi
que je conçois ces deux domaines tout à
fait différent et mon bouquin puisque
avait la gentillesse d'en parler le
cabinet des douze n'est pas du tout un
livre politique
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il a eu du
succès tracer des parallèles entre la
politique et là je suis bien c'est moi
même et c'est à dire très subjectif mais
s'il a bien marché c'est parce que la
fois pour des gens très érudit et pour
des gens qui n'y connaissent rien
c'est une bonne introduction à l'art
français et vous quels points communs
vous voyez entre l'artiste et l'homme
politique il n'ya pas beaucoup de points
communs mais pas beaucoup le et 96,6 me
chez certains non il n'y a pas beaucoup
de points communs et c'est ce qui
explique probablement que assez peu
d'hommes politiques ont une vraie
culture artistique
il y avait
clémence on le sait est très ami avec
money georges pompidou bien sûr
mitterrand aimait beaucoup de la
littérature mais la peinture
c'était pas c'est pas son affaire mais
quand même là les barreaux il tuerait
des très présent dans ses comptes iv
très cultivé parce qu'ils avaient une
formation humaniste il avait le recul de
l'historien du géographe
mais les qualités ne sont pas les mêmes
l'artiste crée d'une autre manière
l'artiste a besoin de tant de besoin de
se ressourcer de de rentrer en lui-même
l'homme politique est un acteur c'est
quelqu'un qui va au devant d'eux est
dans l'urgence l'homme politique trop
souvent trop c'est ce que dénonce et
gilles finchelstein dans son lit la
région et beaucoup d'autres moi j'ai
réfléchi bien sûr sur la différence
entre l'homme politique aujourd'hui et
il ya quelques années où d'anciens
premiers ministres nommés risquant même
et il ya plusieurs changements majeurs
avant d'être pendant il fallait prendre
peu de décision avec beaucoup de
préparation et un horizon qui était
immobile aujourd'hui il faut prendre
beaucoup de décisions sans beaucoup de
préparation avec un horizon qui changent
et les oncles communication et qu'est ce
que je vais vous dire avec le regard
permanent des médias
c'est donc beaucoup plus compliqué et on
parlait de terre de mitterrand
mitterrand disait toujours l'homme
d'état t'aime pareil que l'homme
politique c'est quelqu'un qui sait
résister et anticiper je pense que ça
c'est très bien mais presse locale jean
le sujet tout à leur parle d' absolue
c'est le point commun qu'ils voient
entre l'artiste et l'homme politique et
cet engagement c'est absolue et en plus
que c'est un grand artiste vous savez je
suis touché par son analyse il ya
peut-être un point commun mais ce serait
une longue discussion
vous savez malraux parlait beaucoup de
l'art comme anti destin comme manière de
fond surmonter la pente naturelle de
l'isla je pense que dans dans le cas de
beaucoup d'hommes politiques
au fond c'est une manière de surmonter
sa propre mort de surmonter le temps qui
passe parce qu'à partir du moment où
vous inscrivez dans le champ politique
et au fond vous allez au delà de votre
propre temps de vie parce que vous
réaliser des choses qui resteront très
près par françois mitterrand c'était
vrai pour mitterrand qui était obsédé
par la mort et d'ailleurs et la trace
qu'il allait le jeu et je réfléchissais
à salière au fond le slogan c'était
changer la vie mais la mesure qui a le
plus marqué c'est quand il a changé la
mort avec la suppression de la peine de
mort bien sûr juste pour revenir à
l'arrêt au marché l'art actuel je sais
pas si vous avez lu dans le monde du
week-end dernier
cette tribune de jean clair qui dénonce
l art des traders il dénonce en fait la
spéculation financière qui existent
aujourd'hui autour des oeuvres est dû à
des marches ont dit vous êtes d'accord
c'est pour l'art contemporain bien sûr
mais dans l'art contemporain j'explique
ça quand je fais les conférences autour
de mon livre il ya la fois des grands
chefs-d'oeuvre et des choses nous avait
pas beaucoup vous l'art contemporain
c'est une autre section de cuivres oui
enfin s'il ya chapitre le dernier sur
soulagé quand même le plus grand peintre
contemporain est un homme remarquable
mais j'explique que dans l'art
contemporain comme d'ailleurs dans l'art
classique il y à la fois des grands
chefs-d'oeuvre
est ce que j'appelle le ssc l'école
snowball spéculative il y a pour moi est
évident comme je suis parent est il
devenu un spécialiste peut porter
jugement va t-il il ya des choses
magnifiques et des gens qui n'ont pas de
talent mais avec lesquels on fait des
opérations financières
mais avec le temps finalement les vrais
chef-d'oeuvre apparaissent il ya un
livre un film pardon on va peut-être
beaucoup parler dans les semaines qui va
venir qui va être présenté à cannes
c'est le film la conquête de xavier
durringer sur l'axé wake sur l'accession
au pouvoir de nicolas sarkozy
vous irez le voir vous avez envie de le
voir ce film pas tellement non parce que
je on à l'original à la télévision
bataille soit on va pas sur votre chaîne
à cindy fils quand même oci scories
président libyen discours c'est normal
non mais si vous voulez je ne sais pas
ce qu'il ya dedans dans le film c'est
toujours très très difficile de faire
des films sur une actualité politique
immédiate
on peut dire que c'est une première en
france oui et puis moi je suis pas
si vous voulez le cinéma pour moi c'est
le divertissement et la politique c'est
pas le divertissement donc je mêle pas
trop les deux choses vous n'avez pas de
curiosité d'une façon générale sur les
livres ou les films qui parlent de
politique contemporain saison que c'est
vrai et que s'agissant en particulier de
monsieur sarkozy
ma curiosité a eu l'occasion d'être
satisfait qu est-ce que vous avez été
voir la pièce d'olivier py à l'odéon sur
les derniers jours de françois
mitterrand non mais il paraît que c'est
très intéressant
moi je n'ai pas vu que j'avais vu en
revanche le film dont j'ai oublié le nom
avec bouquet le promeneur du
champ-de-mars où il y avait un beau
numéro d'acteur vous à fait remarquable
de michel bouquet qu'elles sont vides
vous arrivez vous déconnecter totalement
de la politique dans votre vie oui c'est
nécessaire mais ça j'ai toujours fait
par exemple quand j'étais matignon où il
a pris dans la somme nationale j'ai
jamais habité dans près de mon bureau je
pense que c'est très nécessaire comme
antidote pour les hommes politiques en
particulier de deux importants enfin qui
ont des grandes responsabilités de
garder un contact et la vie quotidienne
c'est pas du tout vrai de dire qu'ils
sont comme tout le monde mais moi j'aime
me balader j'aime faire mes courses
j'aime et la politique se déconnecte en
plus bon ce que les gens ne savent pas
c'est que la moitié de mon activité
politique c'est une activité politique
locale puisque je prédis c'est
l'agglomération de rouen est donc là
c'est beaucoup plus concret mais tout
cas moi je me sentirais mal à l'aise
d'être tout le temps dans la politique
non quand on vous demande un trait de
votre caractère j'ai lu que vous
répondiez souvent la réserve swisher
paradoxal serre que sur le plan
personnel je suis assez timide et
réservé c'est une espèce de respect que
j'ai pour les autres mais en revanche
dans le champ politique
évidemment cette réserve saute mais
c'est un défaut ou une qualité à vos
yeux
bon c'est un plutôt une qualité humaine
mais c'est un défaut pour la réussite
politique mais est ce que le fait de ne
plus avoir d'ambitions présidentielles
vous a libéré d'une certaine manière
d'une ambition lourde et pesante
non je n'ai pas le sentiment d'être un
homme libéré on a parallèle dont je me
sens bien dans ma peau est très
sérieusement important quand on a comme
vous connu une carrière si brillante cgd
jacques tir mais c'est vrai que c est en
même temps beaucoup de gens me disent
mais tu devrais tu as toutes les
qualités c'est bloqué c'est toi que je
suis très flatté mais je dois confesser
quo ou la micro je dois confesser que ma
fille politique est un échec
épouvantable puisque avoir été premier
ministre ministre des finances deux fois
président massimo nationale mise la
recherche mille d'industrie c'est un
échec
je hais ce que vous avez des cendres on
peut maintenant pour la tête mais
peut-être avec le recul quand même
est-ce que d'avoir été premier ministre
cite aussi jeunes à 37 ans oui mais ça
c'est un soir c'est vrai que j'ai été le
plus jeune paraît-il promise la
république et ça reste
mais chez nous seulement choisit pas le
nombre de gens auxquels on a proposé
d'être premier ministre et qui ont
refusé est assez limité dans le journal
du dimanche
dimanche dernier cette phrase de pierre
bergé je regrette que fabius aient voté
contre le traité constitutionnel en 2005
car si quelqu'un aurait pu battre
sarkozy en 2007 c'était bien lui vous
aussi vous avez déjà géré sur cette
position non non non non il je ne sais
pas si j'aurais pu battre monsieur
sarkozy en scène sur la question du
traité cossu elles vont elle est
derrière nous mais c'est vrai que les
critiques qui ont été faites à l'époque
et qui a été finalement partagé par la
majorité des français trouvent un écho
aujourd'hui puisque quand on nous
dénoncions non pas l'europe contre hamas
qui était dit mais la façon dont se
construisait parce qu'elle n'était pas
assez social parce que au sol que les
institutions et pas des contenus les
politiques parce que monétairement ça
n'allait pas c'est tout ce qu'on est en
train de voir
maintenant ce débat est derrière nous et
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait symbolique
que martine aubry ait confié définition
de la politique internationale du pays
pour le futur globalement collectivement
à quelqu'un qui n'avait pas pris la
position qu'elle avait pris c'est une
volonté d'unité que diriez-vous alors
aujourd'hui avec cette autorité l'a1
notamment ses choix passés laurent
fabius jean pierre chevènement qui
menace de se présenter justement en 2012
parce qu'il estime que le parti
socialiste n'est pas au clair avec le
pacte de stabilité
l'occasion de le voir jean piot nom lui
est resté un bon pour lui non mais on se
rencontre est une occasion privé et je
lui ai dit que nous étions proches sur
beaucoup de sujets par exemple ce pacte
c'est vrai que c'est un pacte
d'austérité --que ils risquent de casser
les éléments de croissance dont on a
besoin en europe par exemple je partage
avec jean pierre chevènement l'idée qu'
il faudrait que notre continent l'europe
exige la réciprocité dans ses relations
commerciales avec la chine d'un côté que
les états unis d'autres donc il ya des
points peut-être sur lequel différents
mais l'idée que nous sommes pour
l'europe qui à reprendre la relation
franco allemande et qu'il faut une
relation beaucoup plus équilibrée et une
europe vraiment qu'il soit plus
indépendante
ça c'est vrai autant de raisons qui font
que jean pierre chevènement ne vois pas
rejouer 2002 ce soit mieux que tout le
monde soit rassemblé oui très bien merci
merci perrine merci monsieur le ministre
ne revirent d'avoir été à gauche ce soir
ben on sera tous serrés semaine
prochaine
il ya des gens qui vivent très mal le
fait date 6 en soliste est le plus
pénible peut-être ces deux d'avoir à
demander tout juin 2009 la prison de
nancy s'apprête à quitter ses vieux murs
du centre ville pour un établissement
tout neuf en périphérie celle de mars et
qui a plus de contacts etc et sur les
rails un petit contact humain en fait
l'occasion pour les réalisateurs
d'interroger le personnel et les docu
sur leurs conditions de vie de travail
et l'affluence du bâtiment sur leur vie
quotidienne
c'est pas parce qu'on est seul dans sa
cellule qu'on est isolé d'une prison à
l'autre
un documentaire de laurence mi-longs et
guy girard dimanche à 9 heures suivi
d'un débat animé par élise lucet
l'immigration c'est un grand sujet la
france est un pays qui s'est construit
par l'ouverture
je veux que la france reste ouverte
accueillante et généreuse et là alors
moi posteriori vous dites là il dit dix
magnifiques
c'est magnifique s'est passé c'est très
joli pour une gestuelle liste de
regarder ce type de geste que c'est ce
qu'on va appeler un lapsus gestuelle en
fait déjà lady l'immigration c'est un
grand problème on attendrait plutôt un
geste qui veut dire grands là il est sûr
c'est un grand premier resserre les
mains et puis toute la suite c'est voilà
la france c'est un pays qui s'est
construit sur l'ouverture je veux que la
france reste ouverte et elissa en
serrant les mains on vraiment un geste
de fermeture complète donc bon si on est
mauvaise langue on peut dire que en
regardant un petit peu sa politique
d'immigration par la suite
rétrospectivement m'a finalement ça
révèle un petit peu ce qu'il annoncé par
ses gestes en 2007
mais c'est vraiment très intéressant de
voir comment les deux ce trip runner
dixon et ça continue comme ça encore
donc c'est violent mais on va voir que
barack obama reste impassible
il répond même avec une petite blague
fortement ue
quand on voit ça de france on dit quand
même quel flegme qu'elle maîtrise quelle
capacité à retourner la situation
en s'appuyant sur des exemples sur le
cas de cette téléspectatrice or la
question c'est ce qu'on pense pareil aux
états unis et que pensez vous
denis lacorne scène sa manière de
répondre de tenter de retourner la
situation
je crois qu'elle est elle est faible il
démontre que sont mus son message est
complètement brouillé c'est à dire que
de ce qu'ils essayent de flatter la
personne en disant vous êtes une mère de
famille responsable j'avais des enfants
bla bla bla et alors que sa grande
préoccupation qui est celle de beaucoup
d'américains aujourd'hui c'est où sont
les nouveaux emplois certes il ya eu un
plan de relance il y avait un plan de
sauvetage des banques
mais où sont les créations d'un poids et
ça obama se garde bien d'en parler c'est
ça le problème
enfin notre mission est de protéger les
français de l'insécurité
aujourd'hui à paris la réalité est que
près d'un auteur de vol sur cinq est un
roumain et à paris un vol commis par un
mineur sur quatre l'est par un mineur
roumain
pourquoi je dis cela j'insiste bien là
dessus il n'est pas question de
stigmatiser telle ou telle population
bien d'autres étrangers sont auteurs de
crimes et de délits bien d'autres alors
je sais pas si vous avez entendu je leur
ai pas tu as donc il n'est pas question
de stigmatiser telle ou telle population
bien d'autres étrangers sont coupables
de crime ou de délit est donc là bon
pour en dédouaner certains on va dire on
englobe tous les autres les étrangers
bien sûr pas les français
alors quand on entend ça ça fait sourire
ça peut faire sourire
la question qu'on se pose c'est un
lapsus ou un calcul politique
je suis prêt si vous avez des pronostics
là dessus une appréciation parierais
comme ça sur un lapsus mais c'est un
mais c'est un lapsus qui correspond à
une strata ils nous disent ainsi série
qui s'inscrit dans une stratégie gêné
général qui est ce que décrivent et
pascal perrineau très justement tout à
l'heure limité parce que ça se mesure
pas encore trop mais limiter l'érosion
d'un électorat de droite passez par le
front national qui retourneraient vers
le fn voilà l'objectif et du coup ça
produit ce genre de lapsus à mon avis
ouais marianne délinquants oui alors oui
je pense que ces dix ans à labsus ou un
langage décomplexée si vous voulez
savoir qu'avec je pense pas que ce soit
purement machiavélique parce que c'est
peut-être pas très adroit finalement sur
le plan politique non pourquoi vous
dites ça pas très adroit parce que le
terme étranger et justement c'est le
terme à ne pas employer
donc vous savez quand on ne veut pas
dire un mot vin aussi évidemment donc je
crois plutôt que l'on va voom à lire
étrangers parce que précisément il peut
être reproché à la droite des trop
manichéenne sur ces sujets là on verrait
un tirage français et étrangers et ça et
voyez les euphémismes les plus les
formules le terme même de rome est une
est en effet miss une façon de ne pas
dire la chose
ou peut-être de ne pas dire boeuf à moi
ça me frappe
mission est de protéger les français
bien d'autres étrangers voilà donc ça je
pense que ça réveille antagonistes du du
lapsus
imaginez que nous avons dix neuf mille
délinquants en france qui ont plus de
cinquante inscriptions condamnation sur
nos fichiers
est-ce qu'on va continuer à les amener
de tribunal à tribunal
de même nous allons réévaluer les motifs
pouvant donner